Remember that time an astronaut diapered herself
and drove across the country to attack a rival?
If you don’t, you should look that up, because
that’s a thing that happened.
But look it up after this video.
Jealousy is a complex emotion that crops up
when we feel threatened, often bringing with
it feelings of fear, insecurity, anger, and
even violence, and a new study done with primates
is shedding some light on how it affects our
brains.
Jealousy is a weird emotion.
I mean, why would we have this irresistible
urge that makes us lurk on Becky’s instagram
to see if she’s hanging out with Chad?
What good does that do us?
One idea is our fear of rejection forces us
to develop strong relationships we fight to
protect.
Some researchers even think that jealousy
might have manifested as a fitness advantage
as humans evolved.
Jealous people boxed out competitors, secured
a mate, and passed on their jealous trait.
But jealousy is a hard emotion to study, at
least in people.
Researchers know that animals are easier to
control in a lab, but people aren’t always
truthful when they give their answers.
That’s why a team of researchers based their
new study on coppery titi monkeys.
This is a monogamous primate species that
forms strong bonds with their partner as well
as mate-guarding that’s similar to romantic
behaviour in humans.
Basically they jelly.
To see what jealousy does to their brain,
the researchers introduced what they called
"jealousy conditions."
They put males in view of their female partner
and introduced her to another male.
As a control the same male money was made
to watch a pair of unknown monkeys interact.
In both cases, the male was filmed during
the viewing and given a brain scan after watching
the others for half an hour.
In the lab as in the wild, titi monkeys were
visibly agitated when confronted with a rival
for their mate -- they arch their back, lash
their tails, and put their hands on their
female to keep them in place.
The brain scans showed hormonal changes associated
with this behaviour.
Heightened activity in the cingulate cortex,which
is associated with social pain, as well as
elevated levels of testosterone and cortisol,
indicating stress.
This study is, admittedly, limited since it
only looked at male monkeys, but it still
adds to growing research that says monogamy
comes down to our brain chemistry, at least
in part.
It seems we’re hard wired to be jealous,
but just try and resist the urge to drive
across the country and pepperspray the new
girlfriend of your two-timing boyfriend husband.
I told you to look that story up.
Want more Seeker?
You can find us on TV under the name SEEKER
NOW!
Watch SEEKER NOW on TBD Wednesdays 9pm/8c!
To find TBD in your area and stream it anywhere,
download the TBD What’s Next app or visit
TBD.COM
If you like this video we are always making
more, subscribe so you don’t miss any.
I think so much about brains, which means
my brain is thinking about itself!
How does it even power thoughts though?
Trace contemplates that here.That’s all
for now, thanks for watching Seeker!